[Music]
Britain is set to leave the European
Union in March 2019 the British public
voted decisively to leave yet the EU is
Britain's most important market and
British businesses aren't access to it
the government has to find a way to
square the circle before the March 2019
exit deadline Norway has faced a similar
dilemma to the one Britain faces now
back in 1994 Norwegians voted against
joining the EU one reason was to protect
its fishing industry which is the
country's second biggest industry after
oil hands Al Gore is the head of the
north of Norway fishing Association and
has been fishing these waters for 30
years
the Norwegian fishermen thought it was a
good idea to stay outside the EU in 1994
when the referendum was held because we
had a good management of our fishery
resources and they were of course afraid
that the large amount of foreign vessels
would come into our waters however
Norway still has to share 90% of its
waters with the EU or risk losing access
to the European market Britain will have
to do something similar
oh I did not join the EU in 1994 and
instead stayed part of the European
Economic Area or IEA
it keeps the economic benefits of single
market membership it has free trade into
the EU without the bureaucracy of being
part of the EU
John Fossum has written a book looking
at what brexit Britain can learn from
Norway we have seamless relations with
the EU in all fundamental aspects of
economic activity it gives stability it
gives predictability and that is what
the economic sector in Norway craves
like Norway Britain's biggest trade
partner is Europe but Theresa May has
said being part of the EEA would keep us
too closely tied to the continent
instead new trade deals will be
negotiated
if Britain adopts the EEA it could help
to solve the Irish border problem
because essentially the EU single market
is extended to the EEA countries Norway
has a relatively open border with Sweden
which would not be the case that they
were not in the EEA
it is very important to maintain an open
border and from a political perspective
both in in terms of brexit the UK as
well as well as Norway Sweden it ensures
peaceful amicable relations open borders
are good for business but it also means
people can move freely between countries
this is a red line most brexit ears are
not willing to cross
[Music]
most who want to leave the EU reject the
Norway model they say it would continue
to embroil Britain in EU regulations
without having any say in how they're
made in 2006 brussels imposed a minimum
import price on Norwegian salmon some
years ago the EU imposed the
countervailing Duty sound and within
this farming industry that meant that we
have to pay higher tariffs on the export
and we also had to find other markets so
that was a very bad situation it takes a
long time to get new market so I think
that will be the same for for Britain
[Music]
Britain has been trying to negotiate a
brexit deal since article 50 was
triggered in March 2017 but little
progress has been made the benefits for
Britain following a similar approach to
Norway of course is that it doesn't need
to undergo a very significant transition
[Music]
the Norway model is not perfect but a
solution similar to the EEA may be the
best option some people are saying that
those that voted no in 1994 they they
won on the next day but they've lost
every day since this could also be a
parallel will break sector Britain can
learn a lot from Norway's experience a
bespoke IEA deal for Britain is possible
as the EU changes it is the cheapest way
to negotiate brexit maintain a working
relationship with the EU and would be
achievable in the timeframe set out by
Theresa May
you
you